une rencontre de gala pour la 2e année
consécutive les seniors de l'AS Montini
le bretonux handbal recevaient les
équipes de France de gendarmerie
masculine et féminine ce jeudi 26
janvier au gymnase Pierrede Coubertin
cette rencontre était programmée dans le
cadre d'un stage des gendarmes en région
parisienne on cherchait un niveau de
national pour nos équipes puisque nos
joueurs nous viennent de toute la France
ils sont gendarmes et ils joue en club
en civil le weekend pour nous on est
très fier de pouvoir recevoir des
équipes une Corporation comme la
gendarmerie pour différentes choses
c'est déjà c'est le rayonnement du club
de Montini au niveau national ça nous
attire du monde ça c'est aussi c'est
c'est glorieux pour nous en venant
affronter montino Bretonneux l'équipe de
France de gendarmerie crée en 2015
voulait mettre en place une cohésion
d'équipe en vue des championnats de
France militaires programmé fin mars
c'est c'est un groupe qui est très
hétérogène donc il y a des filles qui
viennent de de un peu partout de niveau
complètement différents donc c'est une
force qu'il faut utiliser parce parce
que on est obligé du coup de jouer
collectivement pour les équipes seniores
de montigil au Bretonneux cette
rencontre amicale devait permettre aux
joueurs de se maintenir en forme pendant
la trêve hivernale ouais très bon
entraînement parce qu'on joue des
joueurs physiques des joueurs qui ont un
très bon niveau par rapport à nous donc
nous on prend l'expérience et ça doit
nous servir pour la suite chez les
filles ce match de préparation se
termine sur le score de 24 à 18 pour les
gendarmes cétait une bonne équipe bien
préparé assez physique plus physique que
nous et
voilà donc c'est un bon entraînement
pour la suite du championnat bah c'était
top on a mis de l'engagement en défense
on a tout pris du plaisir donc voilà
c'était super ça nous met en confiance
ça soude encore plus le groupe même si
on était déjà bien soudé à la base c'est
top pour nous quoi du côté des garçons
les gendarmes l'ont emporté 42 à 25
contre les mtains les deux structures
devraient se retrouver l'année prochaine
à l'occasion d'un nouveau match
amical